>>> NEW TONIGHT, CNN LEARNING
THAT TRUMP ADVISER KASH PATEL
TESTIFIED YESTERDAY ABOUT THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FOUND AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
THE IMPORTANT THING HERE IS THAT
HE DID THIS WITH IMMUNITY.
HE ANSWERED THE QUESTIONS, HE
DID IT WITH IMMUNITY.
HE HAD INITIALLY DECLINED TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM THE GRAND
JURY BY TAKING THE FIFTH.
THEN A JUDGE GRANTED HIM
IMMUNITY.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE ACTUALLY SAW
YESTERDAY.
TODAY, THOUGH, PATEL IS NOW
DOWNPLAYING HIS TESTIMONY
SAYING, QUOTE, VIA A
SPOKESPERSON, MR. PATEL
CATEGORICALLY DENIES REACHING
ANY IMMUNITY DEAL WITH THE
GOVERNMENT.
RATHER, HIS TESTIMONY WAS
COMPELLED OVER HIS OBJECTION
THROUGH THE ONLY LEGAL MEANS
AVAILABLE TO THE GOVERNMENT, A
GRANT OF LIMITED IMMUNITY.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE BOTH OF YOU
WITH ME HERE TONIGHT.
GEORGE, KASH PATEL WAS A
NATIONAL SECURITY AND DEFENSE
OFFICIAL DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
HE'S IMPORTANT WITH MAR-A-LAGO.
HE GOES IN TODAY AND TESTIFIES,
AND HE'S MAKING A BIG STINK
ABOUT HOW IT WAS COMPELLED, IT
STILL WASN'T FRIENDLY.
BUT YOU USUALLY DON'T GIVE
IMMUNITY UNLESS YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY HAS SOMETHING YOU NEED.
>> HE WAS COMPELLED, THERE'S NO
QUESTION.
AND I THINK HE JUST WANTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE DON'T
THINK HE'S JUST RATTING OUT
TRUMP.
IN TERMS OF THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE IMMUNITY, I MEAN, IT FORCES
HIM TO TESTIFY.
HE WILL GO TO JAIL IF HE SAYS,
I'M NOT ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS.
AND SO IT FORCES HIM TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS UNDER OATH TO
QUESTIONS LIKE, DID DONALD TRUMP
REALLY DO THE BRAIN WAVE
DECLASSIFICATION.
AND IT'S ONE THING TO SAY THAT
ON NEWSMAX OR BREITBART OR SOME
NEWS OUTLET OR RIGHT-WING NEWS
OUTLET THAT THIS HAPPENED.
IT'S ANOTHER THING TO SAY TO A
FEDERAL GRAND JURY UNDER OATH.
>> BECAUSE THERE IS A SERIOUS
PENALTY FOR LYING.
SO, RYAN, OBVIOUSLY THE
STATEMENT THAT CAME OUT WAS
DEFENSE OF TRUMP, I WAS FORCED
TO BE THERE.
BUT HERE'S THE THING.
PATEL HAS, TO YOUR POINT, HE'S
SPOKEN TO A LOT OF MEDIA
OUTLETS.
HE HAS BECOME A VERY FIERCE
DEFENDER OF ANYTHING TRUMP DID
ON THE DOCUMENTS INVESTIGATION.
HERE ARE JUST A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES.
>> THIS ENTIRE RAID ON HIS
HOUSE, I BELIEVE, WAS TO PREVENT
THE DISCLOSURE NOW THAT THE
GOVERNMENT GANGSTERS ARE BACK IN
CHARGE OF THEIR CORRUPT
ACTIVITIES FROM RUSSIA ON DOWN.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE IS A SHOCK
AND AWE CAMPAIGN BASED ON WHAT
"VOGUE" MAGAZINE WOULD'VE DONE
BY A PICTATORIAL DISPLAY OF
SPLASHING AROUND PAPERS ON A
FLOOR.
>> HOW MUCH CAN THEY EXPECT TO
GET OUT OF HIM, THOUGH IF THAT'S
CLEARLY THE ATTITUDE THAT HE
HAS?
>> RIGHT.
SO, HE IS NOT A COOPERATIVE
WITNESS.
AND HE MIGHT SAY I DON'T
REMEMBER, I DON'T RECALL.
BUT IT'S GOING TO BE HARD.
IS HE GOING TO SAY I DON'T
REMEMBER, I DON'T RECALL A
DECLASSIFICATION ORDER?
BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY GETTING
SOMETHING OUT OF HIM.
SO I DO THINK THAT THEY'LL GET
THAT KIND OF INFORMATION.
AND THEN HE OBVIOUSLY SEEMS TO
BE VERY CLOSE TO TRUMP.
TRUMP MAKES HIM A FORMAL
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES IN THE MIDST OF ALL OF
THIS.
SO HE IS A KEY PERSON TO ASK
SOME KEY QUESTIONS, INCLUDING
YOU'VE SPOKEN A LOT ABOUT WHAT
WAS HELD IN THESE DOCUMENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
DID TRUMP EVER GIVE YOU ACCESS?
>> HE CAN'T SAY SO MUCH, I DON'T
RECALL, BECAUSE HE DID SAY HE
RECALLED THAT TRUMP MAGICALLY
DID IT BY THINKING ABOUT IT.
SO, HE RECALLS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK HE HAS TO ANSWER SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS, AND ESPECIALLY
HE SEEMS TO HAVE A DEEP
KNOWLEDGE OF TRUMP'S EVEN PLANS
OF WHAT HE WANTED TO DO WITH THE
DOCUMENTS.
HE'S TALKED ABOUT IT TIME AND
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
SO HE SEEMS TO HAVE A PRETTY
SPECIFIC RECOLLECTION.
>> BUT IF HE DOES HAVE THAT
RECOLLECTION, PROSECUTORS ARE
GOING TO DRILL DOWN WHEN DID IT
HAPPEN, IS THERE A DOCUMENT, WHO
ELSE SAW THIS?
AND THEY'RE GOING TO ASK ALL THE
QUESTIONS THEY CAN THINK OF TO
SHOW THAT HE CAN'T DOCUMENT THIS
AND CAN'T PROVE THIS.
AND THAT SHOWS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS -- AS MUCH AS
ANYTHING, PREPARING FOR TRIAL.
>> SO PREPARING FOR TRIAL,
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
INDICTMENTS.
AND THERE'S ONE THING THAT TRUMP
THINKS HE COULD DO TO STYMIE
THIS, TO COMPLICATE IT.
AND THAT WOULD BE TO ANNOUNCE
HIS BID FOR THE WHITE HOUSE.
SOURCES TELLING CNN THAT IT'S
THE THIRD WEEK OF NOVEMBER THAT
TRUMP AIDES ARE VYING FOR HIM TO
ANNOUNCE HE'S RUNNING FOR 2024.
HOW DOES THIS PLAY?
IF HE ANNOUNCES, WHAT HAPPENS
THEN WITH THE POSSIBLE
INDICTMENT?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S INEVITABLE
THAT HE'S GOING TO ANNOUNCE,
BECAUSE HE CAN'T NOT -- HE'S PUT
HIMSELF OUT THERE.
BUT HE WAS NEVER NOT GOING TO
RUN BECAUSE HE CAN'T DEAL WITH
NOT BEING THE CENTER OF
ATTENTION, AND HE WANTS REVENGE.
THIS WHOLE PSYCHOLOGY OF THE
SITUATION FOR HIM EVEN APART
FROM THE CRIMINAL LIABILITY
POTENTIAL WAS DRIVING HIM TO
RUN.
BUT WITH THE CRIMINAL LIABILITY
POTENTIAL, HE WANTS TO USE THE
POSSIBILITY OF HIS BECOMING
PRESIDENT AGAIN AS A SHIELD
AGAINST PROSECUTION THE WAY HE
USED THE PRESIDENCY AS A SHIELD
FOR FOUR YEARS.
>> BUT IS IT A SHIELD, RYAN?
IF THEY CAN PROVE, AND I
UNDERSTAND THEY WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE IT SO BUTTONED UP.
THEY CAN'T TAKE ANY -- CAN'T
HAVE ANY SORT OF A REAL CASE TO
MAKE.
IS IT A SHIELD?
>> SO, IT'S A SHIELD IF HE
ACTUALLY WON THE WHITE HOUSE
BECAUSE THEN HE GETS FOUR YEARS
OF IMMUNITY.
THERE'S A BY THIS POINT OF A
SHIELD IN A SENSE AS A POLITICAL
CANDIDATE RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
THEY ALSO HAVE PROCEDURES FOR
POLITICAL CANDIDATES.
AND I THINK IT'S ABOUT THAT
NORM.
IT'S ABOUT THE OPTICS.
SO I DO THINK IT IS THIS
QUESTION OF DOES IT CREATE ANY
HESITATION ON THE PART OF
GARLAND BECAUSE DOES IT APPEAR
AS THOUGH HE'S POLITICAL WHEN
WHAT HE'S REALLY DOING IS JUST
APPLYING A LAW TO A PRIVATE
CITIZEN.
>> WHAT DO THEY DO?
>> I THINK THEY HAVE TO GO AND
PROSECUTE HIM.
I THINK THERE IS SO MUCH
EVIDENCE THAT WE HAVE SEEN, AND
WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE ONLY SEEN THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
HE STOLE THE STUFF, THEY FOUND
THE STUFF AT MAR-A-LAGO.
HE JERKED AROUND THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES FOR A YEAR PLUS.
HE HAD PEOPLE LIE ABOUT IT, HE
TRIED TO GET OTHER PEOPLE TO LIE
ABOUT IT.
AND, LO AND BEHOLD, THE
DOCUMENTS WERE THERE.
>> AND JUST TO PUT THE
EXCLAMATION POINT AND WE'RE JU